[Musique]
nous sommes le 14 février 2017 bonsoir
et bienvenue pour cette édition du 7 8
les invités émission dédiée à celles et
ceux qui font l'actualité dans le
département invité aujourd'hui en
plateau sabine caussens qui quitte la
direction du prisme dans quelques jours
avant de prendre sa retraite elle va
évoquer avec nous son passage à saint
quentin en yvelines durant 17 ans nous
reviendront sur les moments forts aussi
de ces dernières années entre
accompagnement d'artistes et animation
du territoire et puis elle stéphanie
ébène et chiropraticien une médecine
naturelle encore peu connue chez nous
mais très développé aux états unis
notamment l'illinois vient de participer
à la promotion de sa profession en tant
que bénévole lors des mondiaux de
handball bonsoir à toutes les deux et
bienvenue en plateau on va parler
culture et sport donc ce soir culture
tout d'abord sabine que ça vous quitter
dans quelques jours maintenant le
président d'elancourt départ à la
retraite
vous partez avec quel sentiment
aujourd'hui à des factions d'avoir du
travail accompli oui oui non mais oui
donc bien sûr le devoir accompli non
mais c'est une satisfaction de plaisir
que j'ai eu à travers tes 10 cette année
le plaisir
ben d'être une actrice et surtout de
diriger un un équipement majeur de
développement culturel à saint quentin
en yvelines puisque le ce titre de ce
théâtre et le prisme mais ce titre de sa
fonction et le centre de développement
artistique
donc on a fait de très belles choses
avec toute l'équipe du prisme pendant
ces 17 années 17 ans avec quelle
philosophie que vous avez voulu
développer alors des points très
particulier que c'est vrai de maître
l'artiste au coeur de ce lieu de vie qui
est peut-être un théâtre et le mettre en
rencontres et en partage avec la
population est également au niveau de la
population de saint quentin en yvelines
amener au plus près la pratique
artistique et la découverte de ces
langages artistiques notamment celui de
la danse
il ya une évolution aussi dû déjà
peut-être de la pratique artistique
pendant 17 ans et puis aussi du public
fur et à mesure des années vous avez
ressenti un changement un changement
radical je serai pas le dire
par contre c'est vrai que quand on alors
parce que le prisme est un théâtre où il
ya à peu près 40 spectacles à peu près
90 représentations c'est un centre de
développement artistique où il ya des
stages des opérations de développement
et de pratiques artistiques avec des
artistes mais il ya aussi un événement
qu'on a piloté pendant treize années qui
était le festival du polar et l'ensemble
de toutes ces de ces trois facettes du
prisme puisque je me plaisait à dire que
le prix savez plusieurs facettes c'était
facile mais voilà et bien permettait
d'avoir un renouvellement du public donc
moi je me rends pas tellement content
s'il avait une différence d'approché par
contre ce dont je me rends compte
vraiment au fil des années c'est que la
population et l'ensemble de ce public
composé de deux personnes de différents
âges de différentes origines avait
vraiment fait du prisme un lieu de vie
et se retrouver là comme c'était une
petite famille particulière reconstituée
mais qui changeait de facet eux aussi
parce qu'ils sont multiples on a vu
quelques images pendant que vous parlez
de ce festival du polar vous et moi qui
étais un moment important de ses 17
années qu'elles ont mais quels ont été
les moments importants de de votre
histoire avec le prisme de ce festival
du polar on peut peut-être déjà revenir
un petit peu dessus oui mais alors deux
choses qui est parce que le festival du
polar comme
comme danse à l'école comme ce que l'on
fait les actions dans les milieux
scolaires c'est véritablement les outils
on va dire et les supports de
l'animation du territoire et c'est la
façon dont on allait à la rencontre de
la population
parce que venir à un spectacle d'un
choix individuel ont choisi de venir
voir tel ou tel spectacle
or quand des artistes et qu'une
proposition artistique arrive à la
rencontre des spectateurs
elle arrive in situ dans leurs lieux
donc le festival du polar avec 80 lieu
dans la ville et donc ça de la
satisfaction a été de prendre le
festival cats quasiment à son origine
elle avait été démarrée par marie noëlle
piste aura et puis de l'amener jusqu'au
festival le plus important du polar en
france c'est pas moi qui l'avais dit
c'est fred vargas donc à une conférence
de presse donc celle qu'il avait déclaré
voilà est donc là du coup ça est ce qui
était vraiment agréable et et j'en suis
contente mais j'y associe tous les gens
qui ont travaillé parce que vous savez
tout seul on n'est rien à plusieurs on
est très fort et c'est donc toute cette
progression avec des parrain des
parrains très connue très reconnu
quelques fois un peu encombrant mais
toujours généreux voilà oui d ouverture
avec des ministres je voyais que vous
passiez les images de catherine tasca
qui a ouvert le polar enfin de très
beaux et 10 ans du polar où il y avait
un plateau magnifique avec voilà jacques
olivier marchal et ainsi de suite et
qu'on a pu voir aussi et puis richard
bohringer aussi oui voilà c'était un par
un peut-être le plus encombrant non oui
mais le plus généreux en fait un il
paraissait très pénible or il est il a
fait tout ce qu'il a dit qu'il ferait
donc voilà un nom mais sam karmann était
très attentionné
yolande moreau devront aussi non mais
c'était des grandes et grands
darroussin aussi il y avait quand même
des grands noms il ya eu des grands noms
prisme vive essaie de s'ouvrir au public
vous l'avez évoqué vous avez évoqué
aussi danse à l'école par exemple il ya
toujours eu cette interaction avec le
territoire avec les écoles avec les
autres équipements culturels
mais cette façon de sublimer en avons
parlé de mon départ à la retraite si je
suis contente ou pas voilà donc du coup
moi j'ai vraiment eu l'impression
d'avoir des frustations dans l'enfance
on n'est pas seuls 1 ce matin sur france
inter y avait des philosophes qui
parlait des émotions des frustrations
donc du coup j'ai ça me comme je savais
que je vouvoyais j'ai pensé à ça et je
me suis dit mais finalement en faisant
tout pour avoir cette matière là avec
les artistes parce qu'en fait c'est les
artistes qui sont aux rencontres et nous
notre travail c'est un travail de
médiation
eh bien ça m'a permis de sublimes et
donc on peut pas faire autrement que
d'être heureux c'est à dire que tout ce
qui était peut-être vu négativement dans
une enfance a été transformée
positivement donc si vous voulez mon
père j'ai fini ma carrière
professionnelle qui d'ailleurs n'est
quand même pas complètement fini je ne
sais pas quels sont les projets qui vont
s'ouvrir un mois mais dans le plus grand
plaisir vous allez suivre justement
l'évolution du prisme l'évolution de la
culture alors l'évolution de la culture
l'évolution du prisme oui j'y resterai
toujours attentive avec un regard
bienveillant d'abord j'ai confié on a
confié que monsieur le président la
direction intérim à dominique benhaim
qui est là depuis pas mal d'années qui
sera faire le chemin nécessaire du
prisme qui est pas très simple un on va
voir comment ça va s'orienter tout ça
dans les prochaines années
mais par contre la culture oui parce que
là il ya une
il va falloir travailler
territorialement sur les politiques
culturelles de la culture on a d'un côté
des politiques qui sont forcés à des
économies on ça je vous fais pas le
schéma vous le connaissez par coeur
d'un autre côté pas beaucoup de projets
de développement culturel des
professionnels qui savent plus trop où
il faut aller et comment il faut faire
donc là il va falloir il ya quand même
des enjeux je pense que voilà mon
conseil est ma petite générosité avant
de partir ça sera que toute initiative
de quartier toute initiative de la
population toute initiative de sportifs
de la santé du social il va falloir
pouvoir l'a relevé et regarder comment
des artistes peuvent venir poser leur
regard posé leurs leurs paroles leurs
écritures de façon à donner une
vision différente parce qu'évidemment
les artistes nous ouvrent une vision
différente sur le monde
donc vous restera engagée c'est pas
possible devait retrouver sa possible et
avec mon plateau on va parler le sport
justement donné crise de médecine
bonsoir stéphanie et ben vous êtes
chiropractie sienna bailly c'est dans
les yvelines vous avez participé au
mondial de handball qui s'organise était
organisée en france et qui a été
remportée par la france pour promouvoir
cette médecine naturelle on va y revenir
mais déjà expliquez-nous votre pratique
médicale la chiropractie ça consiste en
quoi
alors c'est une thérapie manuelle qui
est né en 1895 aux états unis qui a été
créée par daniel d'être palmer c'était
en fait une pratique donc qui vient
notre profession vient du grec donc
caire qui veut dire la main et ractis
qui me dire l'action en fait une
thérapie manuelle basés principalement
en fait sur le détecte et corrige et
ainsi que prévenir les troubles neuro
musculo squelettiques
il ya une vraie différence avec
l'ostéopathie par exemple eh oui alors
l'été contre ne sont pas du tout les
mêmes en fait nous avons des techniques
mécaniquement assister nous avons essayé
des techniques instrumentales en fait
que chacun développe au niveau de son
cabinet que ne trouvaient pas chez
l'ostéopathe effectivement et les
résultats obtenus les résultats sont
assez probant les personnes sans compte
en mouvement et ça s'adresse dès le plus
jeune âge c'est ça s'adresse j'ai flâné
place du midi ça s'adresse depuis le
jeune plus jeunes elles ont très tôt
vous pouvez traiter les enfants les
nouveau-nés jusqu'à la personne âgée est
en fait après tout le monde peut se voir
tout peut dire consulter plus ou moins
sortant d'école après on peut se
spécialiser dans telle ou telle pratique
à chacun de choisir celle ci ce qui
l'intéresse c'est pas si neuf que ça
puisque vous l'avez dit ça date quand
même de quelques années et c'est
principalement connue aux etats-unis et
pas en france mais en europe pourquoi
alors pourquoi parce que la profession y
avons connu en france que depuis 2002 et
les décrets d'application notre
profession date de 2011
donc en fait c'est tout récent et donc
effectivement pendant beaucoup d'années
en fait ça a été pratiquée mais du coup
bas jusqu'au décret 2002 la profession
finalement été reconnu avec
l'ostéopathie d'ailleurs en parlant
et depuis cette reconnaissance est ce
qu'il ya un engouement aussi de près des
patients qui viennent bien sûr et bien
souvent bien sûr bien sûr oui
effectivement du coup de le fait de nous
avoir atteint d'être connue fait que
petit à petit les gens commencent à
s'ouvrir un peu plus sur ces thérapies
là se rendent compte que du goût par
rapport à la médecine classique où
effectivement vous avez un traitement
médicamenteux nous a davantage en fait
une technique très très douces à base
c'est non médicamenteuses justement est
en fait que but du jeu c'est d'essayer
de calmer les douleurs du patient sans
avoir besoin de prendre de médicaments
forcé et pour pratiquer pour exercer
quelle formation
c'est alors il en france il ya qu une
seule école qui a deux poules 1 à paris
à ivry sur seine est l'hôte à toulouse
qui s'appelle direct donc la socia
l'institut franco hors pair de
chiropraxie les années d'études sont
basés sur cinq ans mais votre parcours
vous avez plutôt commencer par la
médecine alors au départ et seulement 10
effectivement j'ai commencé en fait par
deux ans de médecine en sortant de mon
bac j'ai été très orienté effectivement
dans la thérapie bon jouer vraiment
terminé weeds et les gens et ça c'est
quelque chose sur l'occasion chez moi et
du coup j'ai eu l'opportunité en fait
donc j'ai pas eu mon concours et puis du
coup puis tu as ça j'ai pris enfin j'ai
voulu ouvrir voir ce qu'il y avait comme
une thérapie possible et j'ai fait la
connaissance d'un chiropracteur qui a
soigné ma mère pour de multiples
problèmes de dos depuis toujours et en
fait il l'a sorti d'affaires et du coup
je suis allé le voir
j'ai passé une journée chez lui et
c'était la révélation à partir de là je
me suis dit c'est un truc qui
m'intéresse et aujourd'hui vous en
faites la promotion justement de cette
pratique médicale vous avez participé au
championnat du monde de handball je le
disais tout à l'heure
comment vous êtes arrivé sur l'événement
vous êtes venu en tant que bénévole en
plus en physique je vais préciser il n'y
a pas eu d'intervention auprès des
joueurs non dit ou non n'ont pas eu
d'intervention auprès des joueurs on a
pu les voir en action lors des matchs
etc
mais non c'est principalement ça a été
vraiment une action prêtait avec les
bénévoles auprès du staff bénévoles qui
paient veillant sur l'événement on n'y a
été en fait sous l'égide de
l'association française de chiropratique
en fait notre association
professionnelle qui nous représente
c'est à travers eux qui vont faire un
appel auprès des chiropracteurs voir
qu'est-ce qui était partant pour
assister à cet événement là et comme je
suis très intéressé par le domaine du
sportif j'ai pas hésité
et j français vivent un retour positif a
souhaité notamment par exemple la
fédération de hand en france s'est dit
ça pourrait aussi intéresser les joueurs
et ça peut leur permettre aussi d'être
plus performant de récupérer plus vite
c'est ce qu'on espère effectivement
c'est à travers cette initiative
effectivement de se faire connaître de
voir effectivement au niveau des fédés
pour essayer enfin le faire à chaque
fédération pour voir petit à petit si ça
peut déboucher sur ce genre de passe que
des équipes de sport à l'étranger j'en
reviens aux états unis qui ont
directement des chiropracteurs dans leur
staff dans les staffs médicaux
exactement bajus tout récemment en fait
il ya eu donc le super bowl et donc les
patriotes par exemple ont publié les
photos il ya le carreau pour acteurs sur
place ceux qui assistaient lors du match
et puis qu'il faut à les aider parce
qu'il pourrait y présenter des troubles
et les douleurs etc
mais vous aurez bientôt l'occasion une
nouvelle fois d'être d'être bénévole
mais en tout cas une nouvelle fois
d'aller promouvoir votre votre pratique
lors des championnats du monde de hockey
exactement exactement au mois de mai en
fait pareil sur la sur paris et on aura
l'occasion effectivement de pouvoir
remontrer devoir trop faire briller un
petit peu la chiropraxie au milieu de
tout ça il n'y aura pas d'intervention
sur les joueurs non plus norman ans que
je sache non non je pense que ça va être
pareil ça sera vers les bénévoles en est
juste pour conclure cet entretien on
revenir à votre parcours plus personnel
ce monde du sport c'est quelque chose
qui vous intéressent plus justement
d'aller peut-être d'être engagé par une
équipe pourquoi pas c'est effectivement
pourquoi pas une ouverture qui
m'intéresserait beaucoup effectivement
oui parce que c'est un domaine qui m'a
toujours vraiment beaucoup intéressé
depuis vingt deux ans à l'époque où
j'étais étudiante est déjà quelque chose
qui m'a vraiment suscité l'attention
et puis terminer mes études en fait nous
donne la possibilité de pouvoir se
former en fait à travers des séminaires
de techniques spécialisées dans le
domaine du sportif ce que j'ai fait et
ce que je continuerai à faire pour
essayer justement de performer et pour
être de mieux en mieux au niveau de la
prise en charge du sportif est pour
l'instant vous exercer sur bailly est la
question la toute dernière cette fois ci
parce que ça coûte cher est ce que c'est
remboursé
alors est ce que ça coûte cher la
consultation en fait dans le secteur
enfin tant dans les yvelines chacun à
plus ou moins les tarifs qui le
souhaitent
c'était pas réglementé là dessus par
contre au niveau de la prise en charge
vous avez donc effectivement si tu
essaies sociale ne prend pas en charge
par contre avec beaucoup de mutuelle est
de plus en plus comme du coup c'est une
profession qui vous vient à s'ouvrir
petit tactique et ben en fait les
mutuelles commence de plus en plus à
rembourser avec effectivement voilà
c'est plutôt bénéfique pour les patients
parce qu'ils s'en rendent compte et puis
ça leur permet de pouvoir revenir et
vous savez donc aujourd'hui un peu plus
sur cette pratique de la chiropractie
merci d'être venus en plateau merci
encore samedi
profitez bien de ces derniers jours
avant le départ à la retraite du prisme
à elle encore merci à vous l'émission
est à retrouver sur notre site internet
et sur l'application mobile très belle
soirée
[Musique]